To get to this answer of 1/10 faster, I
actually didn't need to wait to simplify.
I could have done it sooner. Let's see
what that looks like. I can reduce any
common factors that appear in the
numerators and in the denominators. I know
if I multiply these fractions, I would do
21 and 54.
I'm going to break up my four into factors
of two. I know 2/2 makes one. So, whenever
I see a 2/2, I can simplify that, then I
would just multiply as usual. 1*1 is one
and 512 is ten, so I still get 1/10. You
might have heard of the term
crosscanceling before, that could also
work. I know that two goes in a two and
two goes in a four. If I would write a
factor in the numerator and at the
denominator, I can cancel. 2/2 makes one,
and 4/2 makes two. When I multiply across,
I'm going to have 11 and 52.
Either way, I still wind up with 1/10. The
key thing is you want to make sure you're
only cancelling that factor that appears
in the numerator and in the denominator,
because we know anything over itself is
one.